[Music]
you're gonna be the new Robocop was this
must've been exciting for you a fan of
the original when it came out I was a
huge fan of the original I saw it
probably like 20 to 25 times I had to
fight hard to get the part
I met with Josie the director and yeah
he really he told this incredible story
that he wanted to tell by using the
concept of Robocop and so I was shooting
the killing in Vancouver and I flew down
to LA three weekends in a row and and
then finally I I got the call and I was
I was lying in bed with my girl and and
I get the call and they they're like you
got it and I'm looking at her and she's
like you woke up and she goes crazy and
she's like we got to do something we got
we got it we got to celebrate so so I
was like all right like what do we do
she's like let's just jump in a pool and
and and I was like oh okay and then she
starts running out I'm like running out
in my underwear and she's like just jump
in the pool I'm like yeah let's jump in
the pool but is it is it is it heated
you know she's like come on you you
you're Robocop just get in the pool and
I'm like all right I'm getting in the
pool and then but I'm still a little
concerned about the the heat of the pool
so so I try to try to dip my toe in it
but but it's the water is kind of low
yeah yeah so I reached down and then I
scratched my butt on the side and I kind
of tire with the pool yeah exactly
I'm like wow I scratched my butt if
she's like just get in the pool and okay
and then I sort of just fall in the pool
and I'm lying there alone in the pool
you're Todd paddling and she's like
you're Robocop
wasn't a good start it wasn't a good
start to his Robocop you just got the
word though you got it now there was
some speculation about you know people
been speculating what's this Robocop
going to look like and then this image
appeared paparazzi took this photo oh
yeah I was just gonna go get the paper
yeah that looks like Robocop sort of
early in the morning he's wandering eyes
oh tell room he's hungover just wants to
get some coffee
I must get coffee and then this picture
came out of someone is shining your butt
yeah is that I guess that must be that
must be a job that someone has which is
maintaining the costume while your
important job that butt needs to be
shined there's not so much going on in
the front you know so the the back side
needs to be very shined yeah he had a
rough job that guy
training your butt his knife job that's
that's what it is a rough job but like
he was also the guy that had to take the
suit off right and and that wasn't
always easy because you know we had to
there was all these different parts he
had to take off and then the final part
was like this there's like a rubber suit
and underneath I was only wearing a
unitard
but in this unit's art you know there
was an opening of course so I could go
to the bathroom and so he had to get on
his knees every day and like pull his
suit down and he was on his knees and
every time he pulled right when he got
it off you know there's a little bump
and then you just and then he pulled it
off and like sometimes my stuff would
kind of come out
[Applause]
that's congratulations
[Applause]
picking up coffee and stuff so he was a
baby coming okay not to get this show
under control now in the film you star
opposite Michael Keaton okay a terrific
actor and you know it's funny we you
know back in the day he was Batman so I
don't know if he ever did he empathize
with you being in the suit because he
was once you know on the set in a Batman
suit so what did he ever like talk you
through it or sort of no empathy from
Michael at all no it was now he was he
was really you know it's my suit was
really uncomfortable and I you know as
soon as I just did a little tweak I was
like he'd be like are you young guys you
got it easy like they they have their to
glue my suit on to my face and my back
still hurts from from you know they had
to pry it in there with the and they had
a wooden stick in there and you know he
just went on and on right like Michael
this was like 30 40 years ago you